verwirrung beim koalitionspartner der
überraschende syrien vorstoß von cdu
chefin kramp karrenbauer irritiert die
spd erstmals werden mieten eingefroren
der beschluss des berliner senats stößt
auf den widerstand der vermieter protest
auf dem trecker die agrar pläne der
bundesregierung bringen mehr
umweltauflagen und die landwirte auf die
barrikaden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute 19 uhr die nachrichten vom sport
hat norbert könig mitgebracht für
gerammt der vorschlag von
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer in nordsyrien eine
international überwachte schutzzone zu
errichten
sorgt in berlin für überraschung und
kritik auch beim koalitionspartner mit
der spd hatte sie ihren vorstoss nicht
abgesprochen einzelheiten nannte kramp
karrenbauer auch heute nicht zum
beispiel ob sie den einsatz deutscher
soldaten befürwortet aus berlin
genetische sie sagen nicht warum sie
sich eine halbe stunde lang getroffen
haben außenminister kanzlerin
verteidigungsministerin und vizekanzler
die spd zumindest hat reichlich
gesprächsbedarf sie ist von den
vorschlägen kramp karrenbauers
überrumpelt worden
keine information vorab lediglich heiko
maas erhielt gestern eine sms also von
sms diplomatie halte ich wenig daraus
wird schnell eine sos diplomatie über
einen solchen vorschlag abschließend zu
entscheiden muss ich seine details
kennen
es gibt aber keine details die gleichen
fragen die unsere verbündete haben diese
fragen haben auch wir das habe ich auch
heute der kollegin aus dem
verteidigungsministerium noch einmal
mitgeteilt
von angela merkel kein wort öffentlich
zum syrien vor schluss der
verteidigungsministerin auch nicht zu
einem möglichen kurswechsel in der
deutschen außenpolitik
intern haben sie und die unions
fraktionsspitze sich hinter kramp
karrenbauer gestellt die hatte auch die
eigenen reihen in mehreren
fernsehinterviews überrascht ich schlage
vor und wünsche mir dass wir eine
international kontrollierte schutzzone
dort einrichten um den kampf gegen den
esv setzen zu können aber auch um
wiederaufbau zu leisten damit menschen
in ihrer heimat wieder zurückkehren
können
aus der opposition kommt größtenteils
kritik vor allem wegen des möglichen
einsatzes der bundeswehr
deutsche soldaten sollten in ein solches
abenteuer ganz sicher nicht geschickt
werden
diese unabgesprochen haid was eigentlich
an stümperhaftigkeit nicht zu überbieten
ist so kann man es einfach nicht machen
die verteidigungsministerin steht mit
ihrem vorschlag vor großen hürden in
berlin die auch international große
hürden auch international frage nach
berlin zu schicken teller banerjee ist
das ganze der versuch eines
befreiungsschlags früher für kramp
karrenbauer
ja so kann man das sicherlich
interpretieren annegret kramp
karrenbauer steht hier quasi mit dem
rücken an der wand in berlin zurzeit sie
hat miserable umfragewerte ihre
beliebtheit ist auf einem tiefstand in
umfragen und innerhalb der union steht
sie im prinzip unter dauerkritik ihre
führungsqualitäten werden angezweifelt
ihr stil wird permanent kritisiert das
haben wir zuletzt auf dem auf dem
deutschlandtag der jungen union gesehen
das ging schon fast bis zur öffentlichen
demütigung durch einige aktionen dort da
brauchte sie eine starke geste und die
hat sie jetzt anscheinend gefunden
sie schafft zwei dinge mit dieser geste
sie bringt zum einen die spd in zugzwang
deren außenminister sie sozusagen das
thema entwendet hat und der jetzt in
gefahr läuft wie ein zögerer dazu stehen
und die union schließt die reihen hinter
ihr die kritiker sind jetzt erst einmal
für zumindest für den jetzigen zeitpunkt
verstummt die das ganze ist allerdings
auch mit einem risiko verbunden denn aus
dieser vermeintlichen tag kraft die sie
da zeigt müssen jetzt auch reale taten
werden dafür braucht sie die zustimmung
des bundestages dafür braucht sie die
unterstützung der internationalen
verbündeten und warum sie sich in dieser
situation ausgerechnet für ein thema
entschieden hat als befreiungsschlag
dass hier in deutschland hoch umstritten
ist und sicher das heißeste eisen in der
deutschen außenpolitik auslandseinsätze
der bundeswehr
diese frage kann nur eine grid kramp
karrenbauer selber beantworten haben sie
vielen dank für die interessante
einordnung schack unterlag energie in
berlin von eu und nato bisher keine
reaktion auf den vorstoß der deutschen
verteidigungsministerin und was sagen
die beiden männer die sich heute in
sotchi trafen um wenige stunden vor ende
der waffenruhe darüber zu sprechen wie
es in nordsyrien nach einmarschierten
weitergeht
christoph festival berichtet der
türkische präsident trifft den
russischen zwei die viel zu sagen haben
in sachen syrien zum vorstoss aus dem
fernen deutschland sagen sie zumindest
offen erst mal nichts stattdessen
freundlich ein paar nette worte zum
guten wetter ihre interessen im
krisengebiet ordnen darum gehts hier
putin will seinen ohnehin großen
einfluss in syrien sichern
erdogan seine sogenannte sicherheitszone
bekommen über beides redet man nicht
offen vor der presse ich glaube dass
diese gespräche helfen können das unsere
operation friedens quell ein erfolg wird
sagt erdogan und putin findet deswegen
ist unser treffen so extrem wichtig
derweil meldet sich im syrischen club
ein dritter zu wort mit neuem
selbstbewusstsein
syriens machthaber assad zum ersten mal
seit jahren auf truppenbesuch im
umkämpften norden erdogan nennt er einen
dieb und erklärt den soldaten die eigene
taktik fünf tage kampfpause dem habe aus
gutem grund zugestimmt
um zeit zu gewinnen damit wir später die
eindringlinge umso effektiver vertreiben
können konkret aus diesem streifen
eigentlich wäre er nach türkischer
vorstellungen 30 kilometer breit und
fast 450 lang und frei von kurdischen
kämpfern die haben aber nur 120
kilometer geräumt zumindest dort sind
türkische kräfte oder ihre verbündeten
bereits nachgerückt kampflos wie sie
sagen doch die waffenruhe ist ohnehin
schon brüchig heute abend läuft sie ab
was dann
zwar hat erdogan inzwischen bestätigt
tatsächlich seien 800 kurdische kämpfer
abgezogen blieben aber noch 1300 anderer
rechnet er vor und droht ihm offen mit
noch härteren vorgehen er sagt mit noch
größerer entschlossenheit der frage nach
istanbul zu ihrer blase die waffenruhe
läuft in zwei stunden aus spielt da die
idee einer internationalen
friedenstruppe bei den kontrahenten in
der region überhaupt eine rolle also die
gespräche zwischen präsident putin und
erdogan sind vor wenigen minuten erst zu
ende gegangen und wir haben was wir
gehört haben dass spielte diese
friedenstruppe erst mal keine rolle wohl
aber klang es so als ob man verständnis
der farbe dass die türkei diese
profession einrichten will dass sie
dorthin
die syrische flüchtlinge in der türkei
zurück siedeln will und präsident putin
sagte dass man sich dabei sehr wohl die
hilfe einer mission der vereinten
nationen aber
was die rückführung und versorgung
dieser flüchtlinge angeht allerdings
sagte er nicht wer diese pufferzone dann
kontrollieren soll das natürlich eine
machtfrage zwischen russland zwischen
der syrischen regierung und der türkei
soll wohl die zusage gegeben haben dass
sich die gpg milizen die kurdische
milizen aus dieser zone zurückziehen
aber wer das letzt letztendlich
kontrolliert das wissen wir nicht die
pressekonferenz dauert in diesen minuten
immer noch an und die frage ist ob man
in dieser frage auch eine annäherung
gefunden hat denn ich denke man will
oder wollte sicherlich verhindern dass
in zwei stunden
wenn die waffenruhe endet wieder die
waffen sprechen und die türkei ihre
offensive gegen die kurdischen milizen
fortsetzen
vielen dank für erklärung heerstraße in
istanbul
das britische parlament debattiert
weiter über den bike city von
premierminister johnson über den von ihm
vorgeschlagenen zeitplan soll noch am
abend abgestimmt werden johnson drohte
damit den deal aus dem parlament zurück
zu ziehen und neuwahlen anzustreben
sollten ihm die abgeordneten ihre
zustimmung verweigern
oppositionsführer kommen kündigte an
seine labour partei werde johnsons kurs
nicht unterstützen
es geht um unsere lebensmittel und darum
wie sie produziert werden
deutschlandweit haben heute tausende
landwirte demonstriert und mit ihren
traktoren innenstädte lahmgelegt ihr
protest richtet sich gegen die geplante
agrarreform der bundesregierung
die sieht unter anderem strengere regeln
fürs dingen vor damit weniger nitrat ins
grundwasser gelangt außerdem sollen
insekten besser geschützt werden
die neuen auflagen für mehr natur und
tierschutz gehenden landwirten aber zu
weit sie fürchten ein höfesterben
wilhelm tacke berichtet aus allen
richtungen sind sie gekommen rund 2000
landwirte mit ihren treckern treffpunkt
die innenstadt von hannover
ihr protest richtet sich gegen immer
neue umweltauflagen
was nicht bedeuten soll dass wir uns
gegen umweltschutz oder verbesserung von
tierhaltung bedingungen sträuben das
überhaupt nicht wir haben aber den
eindruck dass das alles über unsere
köpfe und auch ohne unseren sachverstand
entschieden wird ein reales stross ist
eine der organisatorinnen der kundgebung
die 27 jährige bewirtschaftet einen
milchviehbetrieb mit 150 kühen bei
hannover sie fühlt sich missverstanden
auch landwirte seien für tierwohl und
umweltschutz
doch immer neue auflagen machen ihr zu
schaffen zum beispiel die weitere
verschärfung der düngeverordnung dann
haben wir einfach angst dass unsere
böden durch unterversorgung quasi
ausgelaugt werden das können sie sich so
vorstellen wenn sie pauschal eine diät
eine dauer diät bekommen und 20 prozent
weniger essen sollen das ist einfach
nicht möglich und viele landwirte
fürchten um ihre existenz weil sie durch
die vielen verordnungen nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig sein
die landwirtschaftsministerin verteidigt
die auflagen zum beispiel beim
insektenschutz ich mute den landwirten
einiges zu an veränderung aber ich
verlange nichts wo wir sie an anderer
stelle nicht auch unterstützen
ein beispiel wenn es um das
insektenschutz programm geht wir stellen
50 millionen euro zur verfügung damit
das auch gelingen kann
die landwirte wollen mitreden noch
deswegen demonstrieren sie heute mit
ihren treckern in vielen städten
bundesweit berlin hat als erstes
bundesland einen gesetzlichen mieten
deckel auf den weg gebracht weil sich
die wohnkosten in der hauptstadt in den
letzten zehn jahren mehr als verdoppelt
haben will der rot rot grüne senat die
mieten für fünf jahre einfrieren
das soll für 1,5 millionen wohnungen
gelten die vor 2014 gebaut wurden
außerdem sind bei wieder vermietungen
obergrenzen vorgesehen maximal neun euro
80 pro quadratmeter kaltmiete bis anfang
2020 soll das gesetz durchs
abgeordnetenhaus gültig dann rückwirkend
ab 18 juni dieses jahres silber bessern
nach zähem ringen hat die rot rot grüne
regierung in berlin den ihrer meinung
nach passenden deckel für den
angespannten wohnungsmarkt gefunden
demnach werden die mieten für fünf jahre
eingefroren mit obergrenzen sollen
gelten gestaffelt nach baujahr und
ausstattung für modernisierung darf nur
noch ein euro pro quadratmeter umgelegt
werden
wer mehr braucht muss einen antrag
stellen dass profitieren praktisch alle
mieterinnen und mieter weil sie genau
wissen in den nächsten fünf jahren wird
ihre miete nicht steigen wenn man bisher
überhöhte mieten gezahlt hat eventuell
die sogenannten wuchermieten sogar hat
man jetzt auch eine konkrete absenkung
möglichkeit denn wer mehr als 20 prozent
über der zulässigen mietobergrenze liegt
soll in zukunft seine miete kappen
können erhöht werden darf die miete um
1,3 prozent erst in drei jahren als
inflationsausgleich
die politik reagiert auf den
monatelangen massiven druck der berliner
und bekommt heute für zustimmung der
mieter ich bin ist schon richtig
also es muss was gegen getan werden
ansonsten bezahlt man ziemlich viel für
eine wohnung der mieten decke gilt nicht
für neubauten soll den menschen eine
atempause geben und spekulanten in die
schranken weisen
bau und wohnungsverbände warnen vor
sanierungsstau und vermieter sprechen
von enteignung und einem angriff auf die
marktwirtschaft
das schlimme signal ist leute schaut auf
diese stadt hier zu investieren lohnt
sich nicht wirklich und ist zu riskant
das kann nicht positiv für diese stadt
sein die im wachstum ist und je mehr
neubau braucht wir werden weniger
instandsetzung und weniger
modernisierung haben und damit sind
letztendlich daneben auch die
handwerksbetriebe in dieser stadt stark
betroffen der mieten deckel bleibt
umstritten
der berliner senat muss mit klagen vom
verfassungsgericht rechnen
parlamentswahl gewonnen absolute
mehrheit verloren kann er das foyer
minister trio kann mit seiner liberalen
regierung trotz deutlicher schwächungen
weitermachen
allerdings muss der 47 jährige wohl eine
minderheitsregierung bilden und ist auf
die duldung
anderer parteien angewiesen etwa der
sozialdemokraten
renault kündigte an er werde den kampf
gegen den klimawandel und für ein
schärferes waffengesetz fortsetzen
ein großer tag für japan und seinen
neuen kaiser schon anfang mai hatte
naruhito das amt seines vaters
übernommen doch der weg zum thron ist
lang und voller zeremonien und rituale
heute stand der höhepunkt auf dem
programm naruhito bestieg den
krisenthemen thron im kaiserpalast ulf
röller kaiserwetter gibt es nicht als
naruto den heiligen schrein besucht
gekleidet in einer weißen robe
informiert er die götter über seine
thronbesteigung hofbeamten tragen seine
insignien schwert und juwelen kaiserin
masako folgt im gebührenden abstand in
einem land das seine traditionen verehrt
erstaunt die frage nach einer moderneren
monarchie ein modell sollte der kaiser
nicht sein es soll doch japans
symbolisieren es lebe der kaiser
verkündet der japanische premierminister
aber ein lächeln huscht über nach ritus
gesicht schon viel emotionen für eine
zeremonie die die stille zelebriert der
hofstaat regungslos naruto eingebettet
in uralte traditionen modern sein
lebenslauf er ist der erste kaiser der
im ausland studiert die 2000 gäste leben
eine inthronisierung ohne großen pomp
japans monarchie ist leise wie homogen
ich verspreche an diesem ort japans
frieden zu dienen und dem frieden der
welt
japan hat einen neuen kaiser
er ist der 126 und noch einmal zum thema
syrien die waffenruhe für nordsyrien
wird um noch einmal wird noch mal
verlängert um 150 stunden
beziehungsweise mehr als sechs tage das
teilte soeben der russische
außenminister
damit ja damit sind wir beim sport und
beim tennis und dem auftaktspiel von
alexander zverev beim turnier in basel
arbeit ja und mit einer überraschenden
niederlage
neun tage nach dem verlorenen finale von
shanghai erlebt alexander zverev eine
große enttäuschung gegen taylor fritz
die nummer 31 der weltrangliste
unterlegte tennis weltmeister mit 6 7
und 4 6
das aus in basel in der ersten runde
eine herber rückschlag das typische auf
und ab in's wäre das spiel findet im tie
break des ersten satzes ein höhepunkt
nach 14 0 führung verliert der deutsche
den faden wird dann aber bei 56 einsatz
bei mutig ab
kurz darauf hat zwölf selbst satz ball
lässt sich aber von gegner trainer fritz
weit hinter die grundlinie drängen
verliert den punkt und anschließend auch
den ersten satz
das selbstvertrauen ist dahin im zweiten
satz kassierte deutsch ein frühes break
die leichten fehler häufen sich
bei 524 matchball für den amerikaner
gegen den zverev zuvor schon dreimal
gewonnen hatte der weltranglistensechste
unterliegt 6 7 und 4 zu 6 und muss nun
um die teilnahme am atp finale in london
zittern
ohne marco reus wird borussia dortmund
morgen versuchen die tabellenführung in
der schweren gruppe f der champions
league zu verteidigen der torhungrige
nationalspieler muss erkrankt passen
für die partie bei inter mailand am
samstag hatte ja noch kusshändchen
verteilt marco russ torschütze beim 1 0
sieg gegen mönchengladbach ein grippaler
infekt steckte da schon in war glaube
ich auch klar dass er in der verfassung
keiner drei spiele in einer woche machen
kann und wir hoffen dass er das am
wochenende zum derby wieder dabei ist
ohne seinen kapitän paul schlussphase in
mailand mindestens ein unentschieden an
um der ko phase entscheidend näher zu
kommen
besonderes augenmerk gilt abwehrchef
mats hummels die rufe nach seiner
reaktivierung für die nationalmannschaft
werden nach der langzeitverletzung von
niklas süle immer lauter ein sieg im
giuseppe-meazza-stadion und der bvb wäre
schon sechs punkte vor inter
man wird ja noch träumen dürfen
leverkusen spielt schon bei atletico
madrid die bayern später in piräus so
das wissen wir den augen vielen dank
noch zu einem leuchtturm da geht ja als
ein sinnbild für etwas unverrückbares
nicht so im nordwesten von dänemark da
drohte rückkehr knute für abzustürzen
wegen stetiger erosion der steilküste
die lösung verlegung des stolzen
kolosses 700 tonnen schwer
120 jahre alt stück für stück auf
schienen 70 meter landeinwärts dauerte
weniger als zehn stunden das soll ein
umzugsunternehmen erst mal nachmachen
sommerwetter zum wetter das wird teils
sonnig teils neblig-trüb typisch herbst
eben zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
claus kleber erwartet sie um viertel vor
zehn zum heute-journal und hier freut
sich morgen christian sie was auf sie
und wir wünschen noch einen guten abend
tschüss
[Musik]
genome liebe zuschauer das ruhige
herbstwetter hält an und ohne nebel wird
es ja auch bei uns ungewöhnlich warm 20
grad ende oktober in mitteleuropa
sommerliche wärme haben wir hier über
den balkan am mittelmeer ganz anders
aber am westlichen mittelmeer oder ist
es kühl in spanien und es regnet eine
ganze menge
bei uns fällt kein regen dafür gibt es
dichte nebelfelder heute nacht wieder
vor allen dingen in süddeutschland aber
auch im norden gibt es ein paar
nebelfelder
dazu sind es morgen früh 6 bis 10 grad
und tagsüber ist es dann doch ein
bisschen wolkiger morgen an den küsten
vor allem über schleswig holstein ziehen
die wolken dahin bei diesem schwachen
südwind sonst aber wechseln sonne und
wolken ist ein freundlicher ein
trockener tag genau so wieder
süddeutschland aber da kommt dann der
nebel und hochnebel dazu so zwischen
donau und münchen auch am main oder am
oberrhein ja und er könnte sich dann
vielleicht am nachmittag solisten aber
wir haben leider nur diesen ganz
schwacher nordostwind dazu die
temperaturen steigen noch ein bisschen
an meist sind es 17 bis 20 an den alpen
23 grad bei föhn und nur direkt an den
küsten ist es etwas frischer
der donnerstag wird ganz ähnlich am
freitag wird es von nordwesten wolkiger
und etwas kühler und am samstag wird es
im norden dann ein paar regenschauer
geben und es wird windig ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen abend und machen
sie es gut